justice pour ibrahima police assassin
sous ces slogans se sont rassemblés des
manifestants en hommage à ibrahim à un
jeune guinéen décédé près du
commissariat de la place du nord en
belgique
l'homme de 23 ans filmé un contrôle de
police samedi dernier lorsqu'il aurait
été interpellé en voulant prendre la
fuite
il aurait ensuite perdu connaissance à
son arrivée au commissariat
l'avocat de la famille fustige les
conditions de son arrestation
ibra est ma fille mais la police en
action il ne faisait pas partie de
l'interpellation il exerçait son droit
citoyen de filmer la police même au sein
de la police une note est passée pour
dire tout citoyen le droit de filmer la
police et tous les policiers du royaume
ont été avertis qu'ils peuvent être
filmés et qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont mal réagi
ils se sont énervés 500 personnes
étaient présentes sur les lieux alors
que les autorités avaient fixé une
limite de 100 personnes
des débordements ont mené à de
nombreuses dégradations de mobilier et
un incendie maîtrisé par la suite
la police a procédé à 112 arrestations
administratives incluant 30 mineurs
quatre arrestations judiciaires ont
également eu lieu
toujours selon l'avocat de la famille
l'objectif de cette manifestation
dénoncé le victime bashing et réclamer
justice
la famille espère qu'elle peut avoir
confiance en la justice pour que justice
soit rendue et que la vérité soit connue
on a des éléments qui sont dus victime
bashing visiblement transmis par la
police à des journalistes et j'ai lu et
entendu que ibrahim avait ingurgité des
produits stupéfiants dans sa fuite est
cette information ne peut que venir de
la police et c'est faux ce n'est pas
confirmé par les éléments des enquêtes
bilan de ce rassemblement cinq
ambulances appelés sur place
un manifestants et quatre policiers pris
en charge par les secours des personnes
présentes ont également pris à partie le
véhicule royal du prince philip
alors qu'il passait au milieu des
affrontements le ministre de la justice
condamne les débordements causés par la
manifestation
de son côté le parquet de bruxelles a
ouvert une instruction judiciaire pour
homicide involontaire afin de déterminer
les conditions exactes du décès
d'ibrahima